And that brings us to financial resources, is how are we going to get this start-up off the ground?
If you're doing a web, mobile, ??? seem quite possible
that you could get the company started with your credit cards, friends and family,
crowdfunding like quick starter, local angels that is investors
who are not professional venture capitalists, but might make some small investments.
Again, if all you  need is a laptop and Amazon Web Services account,
you could be up and running developing an app
but just keep in mind that when you're asked to do the financial calculations,
there might be great to actually code the app but how are you going to create
customer relationships and get, keep, and grow your business,
and so financial resources actually gets you back to thinking about other demand creation activities
in customer relationships and the cost of your channel as well,
so while you could get started here, it's interesting to start pre-computing
what other amounts of capital I will need later on in the life cycle of my company.
If if you have something in a physical channel or something in the enterprise
that requires millions of dollars, I just thought, you're more than likely
to approach venture capital firms or corporate partners,
so not only can you get money from corporate partners,
from the United States, there's some government financing that's available that
??? coming from a university, the first place I would ??? what are called, SBIR or STTR grants
and later be as large as half a million dollars to commercialize your company or your technology.
Also, the small business administration in the United States offers grants
to small businesses to start their companies.
In your country, there might be the equivalent of government fund.
Now, once your start-up is up and running and you're generating orders and revenue,
there are some other alternatives, so for example, you might be able to go to a bank
and hand them finance, the lease of expensive physical equipment.
You're buying tons of computers or vehicles or manufacturing a ???.
You might actually be able to get what's called the lease lines, so you don't have to pay cash for them.
The second is if you actually have purchase orders from customers,
but these customers don't pay for an extended period of time,
60, 90, 180 days, you could actually take those confirmed purchase orders
to keep what's called factors and factors make a business
out of kind of lending you money on that purchase order at a discount.
And so if you need cash, factoring is a normal part of financing in certain industries ???
And then finally, if you're buying expensive component,
typically hardware in building your system, the vendor clearly wants to sell that equipment to you
but you might not have that cash upfront or cash is more important than your mother right now
and your start-up, and so you're trying to conserve it.
You sometimes can actually get a venture to finance or defer or loan you
the money to buy their own ??? and that's another way to kind of preserve your financial resources.